guys first of all I gotta say I saw this
film last night the audience loved it I
loved it everyone was cheering it was it
was fantastic experience being in there
with everyone enjoying this one Chris I
want to know from you is there a moment
when you're making a film certainly one
like this where you think to yourself we
got it like I yes I know this is going
to connect this is going to be fun
people are going to love it absolutely
not filmmaking is the biggest crap shoot
of all time your experience making a
film has absolutely no bearing on
whether or not it's going to work out
there are too many people above and
beyond
um the acting portion of it that can uh
that can Cloud it thank God this was a
case where the experience we had on set
matched uh God willing what people are
perceiving in it which was a great
amount of Joy a great amount of
imagination and creativity
um
this is a rare Beast where what you see
on the page what I read on the page two
and a half three years ago managed to
come out exactly the way that I imagined
it would be on the screening even better
um and the spirit of DnD that John and
Jonathan captured so well
um which is this Spirit of positivity
and collaboration and creativity and
Imagination uh I think is on the screen
and hopefully is what people are
responding to
absolutely Michelle you've got some d d
players some dungeon Masters in your
life were you ever at all a bit nervous
that you know they might not think this
was it like we gotta I wouldn't touch it
with a 10-foot pole if I didn't believe
there was love and respect for the
legacy of the game are you talking about
40 years of this thing being around over
40 years and when you're touching an IP
that that has that much kind of
that many thousands of Imagine thousands
of people around the world playing
hundreds of thousands of hours of this
stuff and that is is the audience that
you're performing for on top of new
people who might like the story I would
definitely want to make sure that the
directors and and the writers of of this
production really care
and I saw that in the script and that's
why you see me here but yeah I
definitely wouldn't I wouldn't touch it
if I would you know what I mean no way
you're kidding me I'd be too scared
now we've of course got the different
classes for characters and DND right
your Mages your Druids your warriors uh
Michelle if you can look at Chris
despite what he plays in the film what
is his actual character class in real
life what would you say oh my God I
think they coined him perfectly the
little that I've gotten to know of him
just working together you know over the
course of the last two years I gotta say
he's a bard
I mean to the T like it's a perfect
character for him I couldn't imagine him
doing anything else like being another
character he's just really he's a good
part
you know
he's got that voice he's got that
beautiful beautiful voice
it's classic The Bard is is is a
character that that you know I mean even
in in ancient times is uh it carries a
lot of weight it's
um you're you're talking about a
creature that that understands uh human
interaction communication more than the
showing where was the you got me a book
about the jester yes the fool the fool
yeah the fool yeah and how every culture
around the world has either the
Byzantium full in Christianity but these
guys were wise men and they were able
through comedy to to teach some some
deep stuff and so I always I I'm an
actress and also my agent
laughs
you know anytime I'm here
[Music]
guys I again congratulations on this
film I'm I'm really looking forward to
taking some friends to see it
um great talking to you guys thank you
very much Cheers Cheers